program
or about the session rather okay
Lacrosse Wisconsin cool
Angola algebra
Angola
Jamestown North Carolina India
Korean Guinea nope I hope I pronounced
that Rick
can't tell if it's Conakry or konakri
um
apologize uh Cara
the first state in Nigeria Mozambique
Sri Lanka
Ganda Pakistan Philippines
thank you for joining from the
Philippines I know it's extremely late
or
possibly very early depending on your
perspective
I think I saw Muscat
Marietta from the DC area hmm
Suriname in South America
I don't know that
I had just seen a
brief item about Suriname
Tick Tock I think it was talking about
the the
empty area of the country between
the main part of Suriname and Venezuela
in defense defense in depth to make sure
that uh
territorial claims don't get enforced
because the Venezuelan Army could never
get through the jungle
so thank you all for this
and uh let's get started I'm going to go
ahead
and
timer has expired obviously it's time to
go ahead
um
just a moment here
I will share
main presentation
and this is going to be a conversation
between me and Brian so we're
focusing on our conversation on the
content of the slides they're just there
for illustration but this is
hold on a second Zoom to me when I
switch screens so I will be back in just
a second sure sure
it has a vendetta against me
yeah
all right
apologize for that again
I don't know what
ancestor of Zoom I offended but yes
it's sworn Revenge
um so we're going to be doing a program
over about lean Six Sigma certification
with a program oh it's doing it again I
hope that this is not going to be
on a second okay
University of Amherst at uh
eisenberg's management
and
this is new
and I think we're still waiting for a
Stuart to rejoin but uh if you are
joining us uh last few minutes here love
to hear where you're coming from pop
that into chat it's got a wide range of
participants from around the world makes
it uh I think see sessions really
exciting so glad uh everyone's able to
join us I know for some of you it's
probably either very early very very
late
so it'll make this engaging and uh and
informative so you get some benefits
from from joining us
yeah I am back
doesn't say I'm Stuart anymore but I
will fix that later
um so there's a program overview
is going to talk about
Sigma
program
is doing it again
I have to send this over to you and ask
you to to share your screen yeah
absolutely
you have the uh information I sent you
yesterday
let me just check I emailed this to you
oh he did okay wonderful yeah let me
just bring that up real quick then
okay
um
very sorry for that this is uh something
new this is this is
it happens right technology sometimes
it's yeah your best friend other times
it can uh be a real childhood can you
see my screen yes I can't uh that's not
the one
oh that's not oh sorry you know what I I
emailed this to you last night I'm sorry
about that all right let me uh
let me see if I can
find that hang on one second you know I
think you emailed me an email but I'm
not sure it included the attachment
you might need to just quickly resend
that all right let me
but yes arms with that I can do the
presenting I guess uh yeah I'm just
showing the one we did the last time
right the uh
hold on a second here
as you can tell Stu and I do there's a
lot
yeah there's just
never kicks me off this many times
okay except
yeah that's so unusual
it's like you said it's got to Vendetta
against you
and you are correct I did not send the
deck
as you're Gathering uh that information
looks like we've got a lot of uh man
Bangladesh Jordan India Kurdistan Zambia
and let's talk about while we're while
we're having this happen
um
talk about lean Six Sigma in general
what is lean six Sigmund why is it
important
yeah that that's a great question and in
fact um almost like the name suggests
we've got lean and we've got Six Sigma
now they partner very effectively but
they really represent two uh different
bodies of thought uh lean places a lot
of emphasis on waste reduction how do we
become more efficient how do we identify
areas that are maybe causing delays or
creating defects just really being
actively aware of things that are making
it harder for us to deliver value
efficiently and effectively the Six
Sigma part is where in settings where
we've got lots of Rich data think of a
manufacturing plant producing a lot of
Widgets or items for Market Six Sigma
gives us a lot of detailed data analytic
tools so we can really understand how
well the process behaving is it
conforming to a standard that we have
and when we blend these two together
lean Six Sigma this is where we really
unlock a lot of value we get an
opportunity to kind of identify where
there are waste areas so we can Target
them make sure we're kind of finding the
ways to be most effective and efficient
so that's really what it's it stands for
and I know you you mentioned you've got
some background having worked with this
way back in the day right Stuart
oh and did I lose you again I might have
I am back okay yay yes I was I was just
talking a little bit about lean Six
Sigma yeah and sort of what what it
recognizes but I think as you and I have
talked a little bit before this really
has its roots back in you know uh
Japanese manufacturing uh period in the
50s and going on to the 60s remember the
Japanese Miracle as they came out of
World War II and some of the devastation
they experienced in that uh huge War so
uh so this is really where you know the
roots of lean came from and it's just
been expanded and now made its way into
so many Industries around the world yeah
for the thought of the Japanese
manufacturing miracle in quality
management and production uh operations
management came from American sources
people who were brought over to Japan
after World War II to help rebuild the
economy there
and these are people who had developed
theories and techniques
uh that they couldn't get American
manufacturers to listen to Because
American manufacturers could sell
anything regardless of
you know how expensive it was or what
the quality was but the Japanese had to
be more efficient
and they really took on to that
um it came back to the United States in
the 1980s
trend for Kaizen and
management techniques of manufacturing
and Six Sigma developed in parallel in
terms of
statistical process control
and looking at how to
keep processes operating
within the tolerances for good quality
deliverable product looking for
variations
adjusting your systems
so that you can prevent problems the old
adage that came out of the the
manufacturing quality Revolution is
quality is free because
if you produce quality products then you
don't have to deal with customer
complaints you don't have to repair the
product
don't have to send out Replacements
um to all of and you don't have to scrap
ones that don't work so all those cost
factors all of those waste factors
are eliminated and that's where the lean
comes from right right yeah exactly
right so all right so can you see my
screen now
yes I see your screen there awesome all
right so I think we're we're ready now
just want to kind of go through some of
the ground rules and yes I apologize to
our audience for all of this uh delay up
front
um I'll troubleshoot my system after the
webinar but in the meantime put your
questions in the Q a box please um the
session is being recorded
we will send you a follow-up email with
a link to this recording
um and uh
bonus offer that's actually not part of
this webinar so we'll send a link with
the recording he's gone ahead to the
next slide
all right
we've talked a little bit about y6igma
we'll talk a little bit more about that
I am going to ask you a few questions
along the way uh through the polls so
just keep an eye out for that we'll talk
about
this program in particular what it
offers why it's different from your
types of certification training programs
you might have looked at
and we'll talk specifically about what
makes it effective for you we'll look a
little bit at past learners
testimonials
um and we'll talk to you about your
enrollment steps the cost of the program
how to get started
when we're scheduling the next cohort
and then we'll move into q a we'll
answer your questions live with Brian
here
right if you want to go ahead I will
think
to launch this first poll
and we want to understand in the
audience here you've been gracious
enough to tell us where you're from can
you tell us how much experience you have
and this is a factor because
uh lean Six Sigma certification does
require that you have
some experience in the different levels
of
certification that you can earn based on
the experience you bring to the to the
process that is that fair to say Brian
yes absolutely yeah we're really gonna I
think if you want to pursue the the
formal certifications and that give you
those uh acronyms at the end of your
title and you can put a LinkedIn profile
Etc uh you will be expected to have
three to five years of experience and
really what we're going to look for is
we're going to draw from that experience
so you can build out a uh a really
powerful lean Six Sigma case study
and a lot of you more than half of our
audience today have more than five years
of experience in the workplace some of
you are still students and some of you
are in in between in first few years of
your of your career
um this as Brian said program has a lot
to offer every one of you
um and for some of you it will give you
the opportunity to immediately follow up
on Greenbelt and Black Belt
certification so
let's move on okay well this is this is
me yeah this is you this is you please
please tell please tell everybody about
yourself absolutely so uh so as you can
see I've got a lot of those same
acronyms uh after my name uh PMP is the
project management professional pgmp is
program management we've got an agile
certified professional that's very uh
trendy area so I spent a lot of time
these days particularly as an agile
coach I also have my lean Six Sigma
certifications and have taught that
course a number of times uh and all this
is a reflection of the fact that I've
been doing this work for a long time
over 25 years primarily in the project
program management domain
um but uh that's been across a number of
different Industries and organizations
um you might pick up possibly a little
bit of a accent a Texas accent perhaps
because I am based in Houston Texas
yeehaw and as a result do a lot of work
with some of the super Majors company
like Exxon Mobil BP
although more recently
um getting a lot of uh opportunity to
work with Health Care organizations
Cigna Humana there's a lot of interest
in those domains particularly because
they're dealing with vast numbers of not
just customers and people that need
those services but data that comes from
it so they're using a lot of these
techniques lean Six Sigma both to find
ways to kind of streamline Healthcare
Services they're providing to their
customers but also analyzing that data
using some of these lean Six Sigma
techniques that we heard Stuart
mentioned so they can understand that
their processes are being you know
uniformly consistently applied so really
interesting to kind of see some of these
ideas and techniques and and how they're
being applied in these organizations
um in addition I I do a lot of work
simply learned happy to have been
working with them gosh I think I'm
coming up to maybe my my 10-year
anniversary here soon uh so I've had a
lot of exposure working both in
developing content as well as delivering
sections like this as well as just
delivering uh training certification
sessions
thank you so much
I've always I'm very grateful in that
we're fortunate to get you in one of
these sessions because you bring a lot
of
a background and experience so let's
move to the next
and this is where we get to brag a
little bit on simply learn simply
learning is the number one online boot
camp
we have helped over 5 million
professionals worldwide in the last 13
years
um add to their digital skill sets we
specialize digital skills skills for the
digital economy ranging from project
management to data science to artificial
intelligence machine learning
digital marketing through blockchain
to full stack web development really the
entire range of various digital skills
and our website
showcases that but we're proud of
various Awards one most recently the
silver award
customer service with
Stevie organization
top 20 consistently top 20 company for
it and Technical Training my training
industry and we got pretty far in the
edtech awards so our products are
recognized and our services are
recognized as World leading and we're
very proud of that so let's go to again
y6igma about lean Sig queers and lean
six Sigmund just to
um
clarify what lean what the Six Sigma
refers to
statistics when you look at the normal
curve the bell curve and you look at the
standard deviation from the from the
mean
uh
Sigma refers to that standard deviation
and each level of standard deviation you
move moves you farther out the curve so
when your Six Sigma from that mean
you are at the Stream
narrow tails of the curve either above
or below the mean
that means that if you can reduce your
waste and your errors that level Six
Sigma from the mean that means that your
error rates extremely small and your
quality rate therefore is very high
said before quality is free so you're
avoiding all of that waste and that
feeds back to the lean principle so did
I describe that correctly yeah yeah
absolutely and you know a couple things
just kind of maybe uh you know heighten
that when we think of those those lean
thing those Six Sigma deviation from
that mean if you get to that point
you're dealing with about three defects
in a million so you're really getting
the point that you have a very efficient
effective high quality process that
you're operating so uh this is
particularly important in domains where
you are producing maybe manufactured
items and you want to ensure that they
have you know High degree of consistency
so when you ship them out they work the
way it's expected and just as you
highlighted means no returns there's no
customer uh support or service issues
your brand is really important so you
don't want it associated with the uh
poor quality items so so this is why a
lot of organizations really put a heavy
emphasis on the Six Sigma part of this
the statistical analysis of their
processes and that fits into this lean
concept about how can we become more
efficient by reducing waste and
inefficiencies yeah
and this you know you think of this as
uh oh if you're going to produce a
million bolts that are going to go into
automobiles or you're going to produce
um a million radios or million iPhones
um and you only want three of those to
be defective per million that's that's
one environment where these this
applies but it really applies well
beyond
just the manufacturing environment you
can use this
type of thinking in pretty much any
um
service or industry right oh absolutely
well as I mentioned uh Healthcare great
example um you know one of the goals of
most of the the large Healthcare
Providers here in the US of course is to
reduce uh the the number of illnesses
and
um you know types of injuries who might
agree they look to data to do that so
this is where they're really kind of
analyzing what are the deviations
particularly when it comes to a drug
treatment programs and
um you know types of responses to
different types of Medical Services
so this data is so important uh to so
many different sectors Amazon uses this
heavily Google uses as heavily I know
everyone's been excited about chat GPT a
lot of that is pulling data from these
large you know data uh sources and then
analyzing them with some of these same
statistical models and that that brings
up an interesting point about chat GPT
just as a side light is
um
this type of thinking of defect
reduction is going to have to be part of
the development of how people use chat
GPT because one of the things we know is
that its error rate is far higher than
three Brazilians per million uh there's
a recent report that said that the
use chat GPT to write economics papers
actually made up about 30 of the
citations of other papers that it
so it was venting them out of
thin air so to speak and
um so if you if you publish a paper
where all the citations are not real uh
you're you're not doing anybody's
service so we're going to see this type
of quality thinking going into even
areas like artificial intelligence and
it's really one of the most important
aspects of this type of thing what is
domac
yeah so this is the methodology that we
often see applied within lean Six Sigma
space and it's really sort of a series
of steps we're going to look to we're
going to define the problem we're going
to measure
um how do we know if the problem you
know is is being solved we want to do
some analysis and interpretation and
then we want to control we want to
actually find ways in which we can
adjust our processes so they can form
more to that Six Sigma standard so
that's a framework a methodology that's
used to kind of help us really kind of
understand what problem is it we need to
tackle which is the heaviest most
important problem that we want to look
at first uh most impactful one and get
that address so this is all part of this
whole lean Six Sigma family of
techniques
thank you
um so let's move
think on to the next we have some
interesting questions in the chat
um and just to make sure that we've
answered I think we've covered the under
the purpose of six lean Six Sigma and
how it's used but if you have more
questions about that put those in the Q
a we'll we'll revisit that when we get
to the Q a section
and
all right
uh
so I'm going to modify the chat now so
that we have
uh the ability to talk to just us the
hosts because we're going to try to
focus in on this but I do appreciate the
engagement that's going on because we're
getting some people
um
sharing their knowledge and will have a
chance to do that later when we get to
the Q a I'll re-enable it that way great
um
okay
demand for Quality managers is soaring
I'm using U.S numbers
similar numbers around the world
um
this is and and we have a question where
are we from I'm
based in San Francisco California simply
learned as headquartered in Bangalore
India as well as San Francisco and
Singapore so we have three headquarter
locations now and um we have so quality
manager jobs are growing over the next
couple of years by 10 percent
there's if you look at quality manager
job openings just in the United States
um
indeed lists 10 400 jobs
you might want to look in your local
country at the uh indeed or whatever
local uh job board that you use and see
how many listings there are for people
in quality management position again
quality management is just one of the
positions that uses this type of
understanding right if you're not in a
quality management position you're still
able uh to make excellent use of lean
Six Sigma is that correct oh absolutely
yeah I think you know the quality
management role is an important one from
any organizations but you know these
these ideas these Concepts I mean they
can imply in any industry any role
um you know as you heard I'm a project
program manager uh agile coach I use a
lot of lean and Six Sigma uh every day
in in those capacities so it absolutely
is very relevant
um again in many other areas of an
organization yeah and one of my dearest
long time
colleagues we work together for a number
of years and he makes his living as a
consultant in the lean space and the
biggest part of his uh business is to
run education programs for companies
that go from the CEO all the way down to
every worker on the factory floor or
every worker in the call center uh or
every worker in the hospital
um because
he understands that everyone needs to
know what this way of thinking is about
and good ideas for Waste reduction
quality control can come from anywhere
in an organization so
don't think of this as just qualifying
you for a quality manager job it will
but you have ways to apply this and many
other parts of
industry or many other roles that you
may be let's go on okay
so again looking at Glassdoor and you
look at just randomly looked at
quality manager companies hiring and
these are some of the names that popped
up
at the top of the list
you can see Gilead is a biosciences
company
it is in healthcare but it's one of the
advanced
biotech companies that creates drugs
using non-chem you know chemical methods
creating
artificial enzymes and artificial
antibodies and things like that so very
high-end buyer of course is
fertilizers chemicals
medications
Wells Fargo one of the largest banks in
the United States
Kaiser Permanente one of the largest
Healthcare organizations in the United
States
um and of course these others you don't
really need much of production uh Abbott
of course is a huge Healthcare and
pharmaceutical manufacturing company so
it produces medical instruments medical
supplies
so again you think about
uh the need for quality control
is
if you open a
Medical Supply a catheter or some other
instrument while you're performing a
surgery you want to be sure that it
will do the job you're you're going to
do because you don't really have time to
find another one so right yeah these
these are all critical areas but you can
see that there's a big difference
between what Amazon uses
this kind of thinking for versus what
Adobe or Google or Kaiser
Wells Fargo or bear might use it for so
it really applies across this broad
spectrum
uh let's go on okay
so you can tell us about uh these
different types of things and how they
relate to why somebody who's going into
this kind of a role
um why somebody who's using this type of
thinking in their existing role needs to
have
these kinds of things in their toolkit
yeah yeah and that's a great metaphor
you know think of these as as Tools in a
tool kit uh if you're working as a
someone in a lean Six Sigma capacity
you're going to want to draw upon these
so we've already heard about demand
which is a framework methodology we can
use to really analyze problems and
identify the right Solutions uh agile
space that I'm very near and uh close to
is uh is so important for finding ways
to enable teams of people doing the work
to identify continuous Improvement
opportunities and that's a big aspect of
lean Six Sigma you know we're we're
never really finished understanding how
we can be better how we can improve so
agile is a great set of techniques and
practices that enable the people doing
the work to continuously improve just as
you said quality is free but we really
have to embed quality across the people
doing the work across the whole
organization now we've got other
Frameworks that we're going to draw upon
we've got the project management body of
knowledge the pinball so this is how the
project management students sort of laid
out the best most effective way to
approach projects and programs we got
lean Six Sigma itself and this is where
we're going to learn a lot about you
know the different types of waste that
exist and how to identify them how to
reduce them the statistical techniques
we can use to analyze large data sets so
we can understand how a process is
behaving and then we've got a collection
of tools tools that are going to help us
both gather information and manage work
things like jira that's a Work
Management product that allows us to
understand what work teams and people
need to perform the priority of that
we've got minitab which is a very
powerful statistical analysis uh product
that you can use to dig into large data
sets identify some of the patterns that
you see there the statistical variants
and understand ways in which you can
manage that and then we've got products
that some of us might already be quite
familiar with in the Microsoft Office
Suite A lot of times we're going to take
this information from minitab and or
demand and lean Six Sigma techniques and
we need to present that so we're going
to use PowerPoint maybe a Word document
and of course Microsoft Project
a great way to organize a large complex
work initiatives that have lots of
different work streams and people
involved so all these are going to fit
into that toolkit that you mentioned
earlier Stuart and we're going to show
everyone who participates in this
program how to kind of Leverage these
tools in the right setting to get the
results they need thank you
very much
go ahead
okay and I'm going to ask the second
poll question here
and this poll question asks why
are folks in the audience have not yet
undertaken this kind of certification
program What stopped you from doing this
because we know that you're here to
learn about this program what it can do
to help you become a expert in
techniques of lean Six Sigma so how how
is it that you haven't done that before
what is what are the things that have
held you back
leave this open for another 10 seconds
we'll give you a chance you can put in
more than one of the answers and then
hit submit
and we'll close this in five
four three
two one
and
two main concerns of the folks in our
audience today are getting practical
exposure being able to say you know
here's actual examples of the work I did
that show you that I can understand and
do this word use these tools and the
other is finding enough time in a work
schedule
be able to take on a program and
effectively
learn
without interrupting
regular life in your career so let's
talk a little bit about that
move forward
so the ideal program is going to address
those problems of
being flexible enough to meet your
schedule
I'm having Hands-On practice to
demonstrate your practical experience
it's going to the comprehensive
curriculum
that is designed to meet industry
requirements because you want to learn
the things that companies are looking
for in their in their Workforce and you
want to have a an environment where you
get to learn from real people
uh with real live interaction
rather than just watching videos and
hoping that you picked up what's in the
material so
uh
is this a pretty
bare thumbnail of what ideal program
would be
yeah absolutely yeah I I couldn't I
couldn't agree more in fact we heard
that in the poll right you know there's
there's two things that came out one is
I want to learn something practical so I
can apply it I'm looking for a program
that's going to satisfy that I think
this program is a really good fit second
part though is that flexibility of
schedule and uh you know I I can relate
to this I I got my MBA
um after I finish my degree but I was
working full-time I had a family that
needed attention so it was very
difficult to manage uh the demands of
pursuing that education with uh all the
other responsibilities that life brings
upon us so the whole intent of this
program is flexibility so in terms as
you pointed out you've got great ways to
kind of learn online you can you can do
that in a lot of different venues using
everything from a tablet to your mobile
phone to your computer but you also have
the opportunity to connect with and
engage with live instructor-led sessions
uh and just as you pointed out that can
be really valuable to have a place to
ask questions kind of make it a little
bit more engaging and interesting to
kind of pursue your learning so this
program absolutely does all those things
okay so let's go ahead and talk about
the postgraduate program in lean Six
Sigma from University of Massachusetts
at Amherst the Eisenberg School of
Management we'll talk a little bit about
them in a moment it's also powered by
KPMG and kpmgs
one of the world's leading Consulting
management consulting firms and has just
incredible expertise in business and
helping businesses this is a six-month
program we say five to ten hours a week
There's class sessions
when you have live classes those are
what eight hours a week
right that's right
usually either
two hours a night on weeknights for four
nights or else on weekends four hours
Saturday four hours Sunday and
they'll be a line to a schedule where
it'll be as accessible as possible for
people all different time zones but
um
again we talk about the industry line
curriculum we'll show you that a lot of
Hands-On work right
you're going to go through the a little
bit of that with our demonstration
learning management system yep
absolutely and that's so important like
you pointed out and then the live
virtual classrooms that let you interact
with your instructors like Brian but
also with your peers with your your
cohort of fellow students that's really
good because you know sometimes you just
want to be able to say did you get the
same thing out of that lecture that I
got
um
you want to be able to have that kind of
way to compare notes
um
again we say it's flexible to fit your
lifestyle because other than the
scheduled classes
you can do any of the work anytime on a
digital platform this is all delivered
through uh digital means
access it on your desktop your laptop
much of it as Brian said you can do on
your tablet or your smartphone
in terms of
watching some of the pre-recorded
material to get prepared for classes
and so it's all there all available 24x7
it's got a support network behind it
that make sure that even if you're
working on a project at three o'clock in
the morning for some reason uh there's
somebody who can answer a question if
necessary so let's go on and talk about
what you end up with Eisenberg the
Eisenberg School of Management issues
their certificate it's co-signed by the
KPMG and simply learn and because we're
the delivery partner our job is to
provide the platform
uh uh methodology for delivering this to
you
um the curriculum and the
brain power behind it is from the
University and from kpg so you receive a
certificate that is uh
backed up by their full faith and credit
so to speak
um
you can receive three credits
transferable to an online MBA so Brian
said he got his MBA while he was working
I got mine while I was working and
if you wanted to go into the
UMass Amherst
online MBA program
which is separate from
this and
delivered by UMass
you can transfer some credit from
completing this program to help you get
a little bit of a Kickstart uh to your
MBA
um that's a pretty pretty cool benefit
definitely yeah yeah it gives you kind
of a nice learning path to follow yeah
and uh it it illustrates also the fact
that that this type of skill
is an important management skill so
it's not considered just the domain of
quality managers as I mentioned before
it's something that is really important
for people going into General management
Senior Management executive management
to understand
you also get ability to interact with
the Alumni Association and you get
preparation if you want to take the
formal tests for lean Six Sigma Green
Belt and black belt certifications we
prepare you for those
the certifying organizations have some
other requirements you have to fulfill
as I mentioned before in terms of
experience and that type of thing but in
terms of what you need to know for the
tests the formal tests this this pretty
much covers that right yes absolutely so
you'll be in a position to sit down take
that exam and uh and get these these
credentials and and you know put them on
your LinkedIn profile and attach it to
your resume so yes you'll definitely
leave ready to to pass those exams yeah
I've got link six like my green belt uh
not Progressive black belt okay let's
move on sure
and as I mentioned University of Amherst
this is a really
old
well-respected and prestigious
institution one of the leading public
universities in the United States
um has a world class reputation
and
the Eisenberg School of Management was
founded in that post-war era when
management theory was changing some
schools of management
were formed at the end of the 19th
century uh brought some new types of
analytical thinking to management the
Eisenberg School of Management came in
when a whole new idea of
revolutionizing business
was changing in the post-war era so they
have a
very
excellent reputation and history of
almost 75 years now
and we look at the University of
Massachusetts
offering you certificates as we showed
you gives you master classes or you can
hear directly from faculty and It
prepares you for the certification tests
so this is something that people will be
able to be proud of and show off
you know on their resume right right oh
absolutely yeah very well recognized in
fact uh it doesn't matter what part of
the world you're in uh your your
employer or someone looking at your
resume saying UMass Amherst they're
they're going to immediately recognize
that as a as a top tier institution
that's called Global recognition so yeah
great to have this as something on your
resume
thank you and let's talk about KPMG
again
KPMG one of the big four consulting
firms there used to be the big seven
accounting firms in the world over the
years over the decades they went into
management consulting and Consolidated
so now there's big four KPMG is one of
them operates in over a hundred
countries
um in this program it offers master
classes it offers ask me anything
sessions it provides real world case
studies drawn from their experience in
business and it also
mentors you during the final Capstone
project of this program we'll be talking
about what that is but it's really
important
you get that kind of
experience because that will be one of
the best examples of practical
experience you'll be able to show off
so that's a this is a really important
part of the program right isn't it yeah
it really is and I think the way you're
describing it kind of really uh should
help everyone understand this is sort of
what ties everything together this
Capstone project all the techniques
you've been learning you're on demandic
and lean Six Sigma and the tools you've
been uh learning about you know the
Microsoft projects and the uh
um minitab Etc well you're going to
leverage all that and you can apply it
to a real world case study something
that is contemporary something that
organizations Enterprises are dealing
with today and apply these skills in a
very uh intense comprehensive Capstone
project and this is I think going to
specifically address the question a lot
of people had initially which is I'm
looking for something that's going to
give me something very practical and
this is going to be very Hands-On it's
going to be you'll be mentored by an
instructor who's going to help you craft
this develop it to the point that it can
be a Showcase of what you've learned and
how you can apply these skills to in a
real world problem so yeah really the
Capstone project is sort of the the
grand finale you know so this is where
we we end up bringing ourselves to and
use that to really demonstrate what
you've learned yeah and the cool thing
is the person mentoring you is going to
be a
consultant from KPMG who has done this
kind of work in Industry so they'll be
able to guide you to where you can find
the best approach to your solution
they're not going to tell you how to do
it or what to do but they're going to be
able to keep you from falling down
rabbit holes or dead ends blockers or
doubts so let's move
on okay got a question I just saw
somebody pop up in the chat we will be
sending a link to this
recording to you in an email afterwards
so
keep an eye out for that in the next day
or two meanwhile to get into this
program you do not have to have a
programming background so there's some
digital tools that you'll be using but
you don't have to be a programmer or an
expert in digital tools pretty much
everybody today knows how to do things
like Microsoft Office and
how to use the web that type of thing
just while you're here on the webinar
but uh but um you don't really have to
have much more knowledge than that going
into the program
however you have to have a bachelor's
degree
be in any discipline it doesn't have to
be
operations management
computer science
any of the technical areas it can be in
Liberal Arts or any other area
the other thing you need is five years
of work experience
so this program is really for those
folks who in the initial poll said that
they've got more than five years of work
experience
um
or the rest of you there's a lot of
other programs that we have that can get
you
into the process and train for this type
of thing but this particular program has
that requirement so let's move on
talk about how the program prepares you
and and
we built this we just showed as a
staircase because it really is a
step-by-step process isn't it right it
really is yeah and it sort of
emphasizing the fact that we want to
establish a solid foundation that we can
continue to grow and develop your skills
in the space
um one thing that I think makes this uh
particularly powerful Tool uh too as
well is that this um it's a cohort and
really what it means you will be joining
this um this session with a group of
your peers you're all starting at the
same point so you have this induction
session you get a chance to to meet who
you're working with and as we can see
from uh just uh who we have
participating today uh what makes it I
think really exciting is oftentimes
you're working with people from around
the world bringing different industry
and organizational experience but even
different cultural perspectives and that
can be I think very uh Illuminating very
valuable particularly if you're
interested in kind of expanding your
career to establish that you know in our
induction session get you oriented
around how what to expect how to take
advantage of the tooling the simply
learned learning management system and
then rapidly get you into understanding
and learning these Concepts so we start
you off with lean management where they
get you comfortable with what that
represents uh then gets you into some
tooling like minitab and then really
start prepping you for the lean Six
Sigma pardon me areas
um excuses so this is a really important
part of this now if you do want to kind
of take that next step and get those
formal certifications you'll be
positioned to take those exams and then
we bring you back together to get that
Capstone project completed and then
notice on the right hand side we have
selectives so you've got some different
optional paths you can pursue as well
we've got these of course these master
classes offered by KPMG in different
Industries led by experts in those
spaces we've got digital transformation
lean Six Sigma and Healthcare which I
talked a bit about how you can apply it
in technology biology domains so lots of
opportunities to kind of find those
those areas that maybe are a little more
interesting to you or maybe have a
little bit more of a background in so
this sort of makes it very comprehensive
but also kind of a flexible
um program that really you can sculpt to
meet your specific goals yeah and I
should point out the electives are
included in the cost of the program so
we encourage you to take as many of
those as you have interest in and have
time to take
because they really add a lot of value
and flavor to the program
um again as Brian said it's up to you
and based on your particular time
availability and your level of Interest
so you can tailor the program with these
electives as you as you wish
let's move on
we got a couple of examples of case
studies and I don't expect that people
are going to try to read all of these
but I'll just point out the different
areas
Best Buy merging with merging their lean
Six Sigma efforts with the Innovation so
this is looking at a case study that
happened at Best Buy where
they wanted to understand how waste
reduction quality improvement would
factor into their Innovation areas for
new Services new product areas new new
store designs
um air preheater performance Improvement
using the domain domain technology to be
able to
improve an aspect of a product's
performance
looking at
service business of Caesar's casinos
which is a basically an entertainment
and Hospitality business and looking at
how to apply lean principles
waste reduction in that area so again
not a manufacturing environment right
Brian that's that's kind of the opposite
almost yes
there is a production line a feel to it
but it's a very different kind of
production line that we've we're
familiar with think of in Factory and
then
quality at the uh
akshaya Patra Foundation it's just
charitable foundation in India and this
was a way for them to look at how to use
the resources more efficiently to serve
more
potential clients
they serve
food to children and the more
efficiently they can do that the more
children they can help so this is an
another area where we aren't thinking of
this as uh
necessarily A
area limited to for-profit business
enterprises yeah yeah excellent
observation I mean these techniques
apply for-profit non-profit for
different Industries I mean it's
fascinating to see the hospitality
industry represented here with Caesars
casinos but you know the same is true
for Best Buy and you know how to use
these techniques to innovate bring new
products quickly to the market satisfy
customer interest and demands so lots of
very interesting uh real world
contemporary case studies and again as
we mentioned you will be paired with a
KPMG leading industry expert who has
been as familiar has been applying these
techniques for for many many years so
you're going to be able to draw upon
that expertise in addition to what
you've been learning through the the
courses that you've been taking okay and
to just reiterate what Brian talked
about in Capstone projects you can
choose one project out of six different
options uh in different
business domains industry domains
different types of problems
and you then solve that real world
business problem to that project
and you do it Hands-On you do it with
the guidance of your
apmg mentor
and you end up with something that you
can then show off in your portfolio show
off to people that that's impressive to
potential employers
isn't a brand oh absolutely yeah and you
know and I think our term portfolio
because uh really important here because
I mean there's gonna be lots of examples
of work that you want to show to
prospective employers or maybe your
current employer looking for an
opportunity to kind of advance in the
organization
um they're going to want to see examples
so this is great to kind of you know
complete and feel confident that it
really represents your skills and then
sort of bring this out you've got a
portfolio just like an artist you reach
into it you've got to Showcase something
that really speaks to what that an
employer that uh that uh hiring the
person is interested in seeing uh and
and use that kind of Advance your career
yeah
we talked about the different six
choices you have here's a couple of them
one is looking at um
customer dissatisfaction scores how
would go to meeting producer of one of
the online meeting platforms how would
they deal with that problem of
bad interactions they're producing you
think about them as a production
environment they're producing
interactions with their clients with
people who use their service
and they want to reduce the number of
defective or or
improper interactions that cause a
customer dissatisfaction so that's one
possible project another one looking in
a hospital and how to redesign the flow
of peer delivery and patient transport
to make the process more efficient give
you a
anecdote from my friend who I mentioned
earlier was working with a hospital
looking at the number of surgeries that
the hospital could perform and of course
the more surgeries that the hospital can
perform with its available surgical
Suites uh the more Revenue it can
produce as well as the more patients it
can help
and he realized helped them understand
that
their
difficulty turning around a hospital
room for
for other surgery was that they assigned
one cleaner to the surgical Suite
um to do all the preparation to get the
room ready for the next operation
one cleaner could do that in four hours
he pointed out that if you invest in
putting four cleaners to work
to finish that job in one hour
that you can
double or triple the number of surgeries
you can do so it was a a pretty amazing
observation and this is the type of kind
of problem
this Capstone project addresses and
these are the kinds of things that
generally learn how to do in
this program kinds of real world
situations where you can make a
difference
and so one of the nice things about this
area
Brian yeah oh for sure how people can
actually make a difference yeah yeah and
then that's that's what makes and you
know what's often difficult particularly
in large complex Enterprise settings
it's hard to see where these problems
might be you know in fact the hospital's
happening they're probably thinking hey
things are going great we're cleaning
the rooms recently but actually with
some analysis and some of the
statistical support you can point out
you can do this better and uh and and I
think that's what organizations really
are looking for they've got a lot of
opportunity to generate more Revenue
reduce costs increase customer care uh
and it's all within the organization
they don't need to offer new products or
anything they just need to need to get
better at what they're doing today yeah
and they need to think differently and
the the example I used they thought they
were being efficient with their money by
paying one person to do this low-level
job uh and not paying extra for
additional Personnel but what they
realized ultimately was that by taking
on the extra labor costs of uh those
people they could increase the
throughput and
Revenue potential
many fold over the cost of that
additional labor so these kinds of
things are ways to think about
quality and lean Management in terms of
efficiency in terms of profitability in
terms of
quality of service and how many people
you're able to serve and what kind of
benefits you can deliver to the world so
very satisfying area let's go on
um so Professor Robinson uh is uh the
overall director of the program along
with Dr Birch
and and at the School of Management
Eisenberg School of Management UMass
they designed this curriculum to be
aligned to what they hear from industry
people need
what they hear from industry employers
want so they oversee the curriculum
that's the reason why they're able to
put the name of the school onto the onto
the certificate so
this is a really good connection
for for us and for you as learners
so I wanted to mention and you know this
is a representation you see this uh
directly Ryan the the kind of
all-encompassing support can you talk
about the different aspects here yeah
absolutely so you know obviously what
simpler is recognized is so important to
focus on the learner and what they need
in their Learning Journey
um and that's delivered through a
variety of different ways we've got not
just our instructors who are really sort
of a a core Bedrock part of the learning
experience but we've got a program
manager who looks at what the program
offering is making sure it's still
reflective of what the market is looking
for with organizations and Industry are
interested in we've got a cohort manager
who's really going to ensure that that
group of Learners that are all starting
their Learning Journey together you know
feels that camaraderie that opportunity
to kind of interact and collaborate of
course the curriculum and the resources
are so important these are constantly
updated refreshed by simply learn to
make sure that they're you know using
the latest Technologies and applying the
latest learnings and in how Learners
develop these skills and then finding
there's the learning teams and the the
peers that you're going to work with
yourself creating that community so you
as your learning can reach out to
colleagues I know this again as I
mentioned from different places around
the world different Industries and learn
from them through this whole process so
all of that sort of combines together to
kind of enrich the entire learning
experience which I think is a big
differentiator than what you would see
with most other learning organizations
simply learn is really kind of benefited
over its extensive experience the number
of students has taught it's it's really
kind of learned and applied these
techniques so effectively yeah it's very
different from the notion of I'm going
to independently learn by
looking at this material myself and
instead of doing it all on my own it
it focuses on providing you with that
all-encompassing support of people that
are learning alongside you people who
are helping you live with your questions
on people who are concerned with
monitoring your progress and reminding
you to stay on track and all of those
things that help you succeed one of the
reasons why we have a very high success
rate
um
let's move to
I think this is the point where I wanted
you to go ahead and share your screen
and show us what the learning management
system looks like so we can see live
some of these aspects yeah absolutely
and I know we've been we've been kind of
going deep in in sort of what the
experience looks like this is this is
actually what you're going to be using
so this is the Learning Management Sim
system that simply learn has developed
and you saw you know uh very much uh
um uh it's a it's a very mature product
but a lot of awards that associated with
it so uh so in this example here we're
looking at uh you're still on the uh the
PowerPoint there oh my bad okay sorry
I'm gonna have to I think maybe I just
was sharing the
you're just sharing the one application
I think so how about now do you see it
perfect awesome awesome thanks for
bringing it to my attention so yeah so
this is the learning system so to get
there you're going to go to LMS Learning
Management system.simplylearn.com you're
going to log in with your personalized
ID it's going to know who you are and
what courses you have it's going to keep
track of your progress in this
particular example we've got a number of
different courses so you're just going
to see I just want to point out we're
looking at a data analytics program as
just as a typical example of how to use
the the learning management system so
yeah yeah
will of course be the UMass uh lean Six
Sigma that's exactly right yeah so all
these and actually what makes this
program quite powerful is a very common
look and feel so if you've had some
exposure to other simple learn products
and learning experiences this is going
to fit that uh same experience and each
one of these tiles represent the courses
that are available now remember we
talked about the selective so we can
click on the electives uh area two and
see these are the different Alternatives
you can continue to pursue again things
that you've already heard about you know
there's master classes that can be
delivered by a industry expert so all
those I think I'd really encourage you
to to spend time with because I think
they really enhance your learning that
bringing us back to the the core
material here we click on one of these I
think I've got one up here right now
um here's our lean Sigma Green Belt so
we've got a lot of different options
here we've got some self learning that
we can pursue
um this is my name is a really high
quality well-produced videos that you
can follow uh you can see we've got on
the right hand side everything has been
uh structured around a very easy to
follow table contents types uh flow if
you want to come back later to revisit
something you might want to you know get
a fresher on it's very easy to kind of
go back and forth across these it can
pause at any point just like when you're
watching your Netflix show you can pause
it and come back to a later point just
pick up where you left off
um we have live classes so not only can
you follow the content through these
videos but you can enroll in a live
class and you'll see a schedule that'll
appear you can select the class that you
want to attend and join that and you've
got flexibility to join different
classes at different times and then
finally when it's all said and done what
I think is really powerful tool and this
gets us back to getting you ready for
taking something like a lean Sigma
certification exam we've got simulations
that are built into the system so we've
got in this case here's a 100 question
lean Six Sigma
exam that we can take we can take it now
it's going to start the timer keep track
of our our progress make sure we finish
it within the time that's allocated it's
going to give you feedback on how you
did on each one of the questions and
your answers so you can focus on areas
that need a little bit more attention
and the same is going to be true when we
look at some of those
exercises those you know Capstone
projects and other projects you're going
to be using throughout the program
um each one of them is going to kind of
outline a problem you're going to get
the tools necessary to kind of work on
solving that problem and then when you
do that
um you're going to get some feedback so
the whole idea here is we want to give
you lots of different ways in which
you're learning different mechanisms to
access that learning and fit this into
your lifestyle as you're managing all
the other responsibilities that come
with uh having a job family and
everything else correct uh can you show
us what that Community button up the top
does yeah absolutely so another
important part of this is the community
you're part of so let's simply learn has
done is they built out a very rich
Community environment where you can post
questions based on particular
um cohorts or learning topics
um there's it's there's a lot in this
space so you can navigate different
forums you can look at data science and
business analytics project management
certification agile scrum you name it
it's there you've got your cohorts here
each one you can click into you've got
an opportunity to engage with and
connect with your instructors as well as
your peers and then if you need it um
simply learn has 7 by 24 support
available too so it doesn't matter if
you're around the world or it's late at
night if you need some help accessing
information I need support with the
resources you always have a simpler
person available to help you yeah yeah
so each of your courses will have a
board on this community Forum that you
can go to
to talk to your peers in that class to
talk to your professors uh pose
questions and you'll also have like
Brian said the 24x7 support from Simply
learns call the support center where
you'll be able to pose questions and
also ask about the operation or report
any difficulties you have with the
operation for example
I wish I had that with the zoom
any other session here but so
um
but thank you for that Brian let's get
back to the other presentation sure I'm
sorry let me uh bring it back where did
I leave it off it's one of these all
right here we go
yeah so do you want to talk a bit about
sure so as you've pointed out a couple
times the the people you're going to be
in the
program with you're going to join with
cohort and this cohort is going to
include people from many different
companies people who are working
professionals they're going to bring in
their backgrounds their experience
um
they're again as you can see here they
draw into this program people from a
wide range of Industries it's not just
people in manufacturing it's not just
people
information Technologies people across
the Spectrum and from a wide range of
employers as well so you'll be able to
get some
industry networking but also some great
insights for what it's like to work in
these different companies and what it is
that these companies require in these
areas so it's that's a wonderful aspect
of the program
absolutely
and here's some testimonies you can see
more of these on our website we'll send
you a link to some of this information
but
we have Kieran who talked about the the
quality of the curriculum and
content
um we have Nehemiah who uh finished his
program and is looking to develop as a
lean Six Sigma professional focusing on
this area for his career
Rosemary who talked about the different
tools that she learned the certification
she learned and really uh focused on
values she received from her faculty her
instructors and her fellow learners
and finally Aditya who
got a 32 salary hike which is not a bad
thing yeah and so
um one of the things that we offer for
people who are enrolling from India or
from the USA we have job assistant
services available
so these
services are provided in India through
our partnership with IIM jobs in the USA
through Talent Inc we apologize that
they're not currently available in other
countries
but one of the things you get through
this partnership is you get access to
the respective job portals which give
you access to some unique job
opportunities but also give you a way to
apply for jobs in a very discreet and
confidential way
we also provide a resume review and
rewrite services
resumes these days go to machines before
they go to people so they have your
resume in a format that the AI bot can
understand and extract your experience
your skills your talents and match them
to the
job descriptions
and then if you pass that filter your
resume will go in front of a human being
so it still has to be in a format that's
easily digestible by humans attractive
to the eye and then finally the
one-on-one interview service because as
you know to get a job or a promotion
um you do pass through a whole series of
interviews ranging from the phone screen
with HR to the technical interviews with
your potential supervisor and peers to
the management fit interviews that talk
about your ability to be a team player
and your work ethic so all of these
types of interviews require you to put a
different part of yourself on display
getting one-on-one practice with the
real human being
gives you that opportunity so this is
available to you for the six months
after you earn your certificate and
again it's not a job placement program
but it is a job assist program that'll
help you with your job search
so to recap
Brian would you like to go through these
points
absolutely yeah I think you know that
there's a I think a pretty couple of
compelling reasons to consider this as a
strong option if you're interested in
pursuing uh career and lean Six Sigma
first off is is the fact that's been
designed for your success it's it's seen
this remarkable partnership between
simply learn with this extensive
experience and particularly kind of
adult learning and um and and leveraging
all the infrastructure that they built
coupled with the University of Amherst
which at University of Massachusetts
with Amherst and how they've kind of
crafted over uh as you mentioned 75
years of the real world business uh
um experiences and then KPMG which is a
leading Consulting organization so
together they have really partnered to
kind of build something out that's going
to meet the needs of their Learners and
their Industries and the organizations
that are looking for these skills it is
comprehensive it is complete it is
thorough and very importantly it's
flexible so um you know both of us can
relate to it is hard to kind of pursue
these kind of certifications these these
types of postgraduate program level
educational sessions when you you're
working when you have a family when
you've got an active lifestyle so the
fact that you can learn in so many
different ways I think really makes this
very compelling for people
thank you so this is the time where
we're going to ask based on what you've
heard so far
you haven't heard everything but based
on what you've heard so far
are you interested in enrolling in the
program
I'll leave this open for just about 20
seconds it's a yes or no question
I'll close it in about 10
and 3 2 1 hit that submit button
and
so about 80 percent of the folks in our
audience are interested in enrolling in
the program so let's
tell you a little bit more about
the things you want to know we're
showing here pricing in two countries
one is the United States
one is in India
local pricing you can email us at ask us
simply learn.net I'll put that into the
chat but you can ask us there about
pricing in your local country or you can
go to our website
look at the program page to see what the
pricing is now in the US it's 2299
dollars
my fence and cool monthly installments
of 203 a month
um it's
97 999 rupee in India
83.71 a month
we also like to remind people to ask
their employers about tuition
reimbursement
because many people have a benefit from
their company where a company will help
to phrase some of the costs or all the
costs continuing education so so that's
always a great benefit to have Mr Brian
oh absolutely yeah if you can get your
employer to help you with this but you
know part of that is because they see
this as an investment in and use an
employee that you're going to bring back
to the organization so I think their
return on investment is pretty
compelling uh enabling their their
workers to kind of get the access this
learning yeah I mean it's an interesting
thing about the lean methodology and and
reducing waste
you can achieve return on investment on
projects of that type of a hundred to
one or more and
so
investing in you so that you can come
back and teach your company how to do
that is a really great benefit so they
are doing that for you you might
gently suggest to them that this is
something they should do let's go on to
the next one your enrollment steps
so Steph is one is to submit an
application we'll review the application
submit it by email at that it email
address below I will put that into the
chat and the um
the point is that we will verify your
bachelor's degree and your work
experience because those are
prerequisites for the program
so we'll we'll um
ask you to provide some verification for
that
and then
if you qualify we will send you offer
mission
emails now in the chat oops I'm sorry
no the email's not in the chat
it will be a reminder to put your
questions and Q A's in the chat now the
email is in the chat
and the next induction session happens
next week June 12th or classes that
start July 8th when we say hurry limited
seats available this is because
unlike massively online open courses
where
any number of people can sign up because
they're just watching pre-recorded
material this is a live classroom
interaction type of program so we can't
take cohort sizes that are more than 25
or 30 people in order to be able to find
sufficient time
the instructors to devote to each
individual so the cohorts fill up
quickly
if you're interested in starting classes
in July please email us right away and
that brings up our next poll question I
think
if you are interested how soon are you
planning to start
from you
are you looking to start in this July
classes are you looking to start further
down the road
would you like to know about
cohort starts in August or September or
would you like to be
kept in the loop so you can look further
down the road than that
and we always say of course if it's
something that's worth doing that's
going to improve your career in your
life so worth doing sooner than later
but that's a personal choice of course
and I will in the poll here
we'll share the result
so about 40 percent of our audience are
interested in starting sometime in the
July August September time frame
um for those of you looking further out
we recommend that you contact us at ask
us and simply learn about net anyway
because that will give us a chance to
answer any questions you have and then
we'll be able to also keep you in the
loop about future cohorts and future
development and for those of you who
don't meet the five-year criteria for
joining this program you can contact us
at ask us at simplywin.net to ask about
some of the other options you have for
learning about this this area so
um
that's
go on to the Q a yeah right now we have
a lot of
have to apologize to people because
when Zoom kicked me off I lost maybe
some of the people in the some of the
messages in the chat but I will go
through the Q a here and then I'll go
back into the chat and see fine okay
um
shakeman Suarez which is better to learn
lean Six Sigma or just Six Sigma
is there are they separate now well they
they are definitely uh can be viewed
separately uh but of course the reason
they're they're brought together is
because they they complement each other
so effectively I I think you know
generally speaking if you learn one
you're probably going to learn a fair
amount about the other
um and I think a lot of it's going to
depend on the domain you operate in I
will say lean I find is is something you
can really apply everywhere it's really
about asking questions on what kind of
ways you're experiencing what kind of
efficiencies do we want to identify and
that can be something you know you can
do without a lot of statistical analysis
you can just kind of look at how you're
working and find better ways to do it
but Sig Sigma is absolutely going to
channel more of the statistical analysis
and uh you know just being someone open
about this and there's there's a little
bit of math involved not everyone is as
comfortable with that
um but together of course they they sort
of become a fourth multiplier fire so um
conventionally we're going to learn both
at the same time
will this be recognized worldwide
absolutely both for the reputation of
the University of Massachusetts Amherst
but also for kpmg's reputation which is
known worldwide and kpng as I mentioned
operates in the 140 countries
also simply learn of course the
worldwide organization so yes when
people see this they'll be able to refer
back to the people who signed your
certificate and understand that
reputable organizations with a worldwide
reputation
uh
certify that you in fact are able to do
the things you say you can do
um
I had a question about six segment and
software develop lean six segment
software development can you talk a
little bit about that yeah absolutely I
mean this is widely used in the software
development domain
um you know a big part of this is you
mentioned your you heard me mention
agile uh agile is used extensively in
software development and digital
transformation activities and lean's
really important to that hey we're
trying to find ways in which we can
rapidly understand you know features
that a customer might want in a software
product uh find ways in which we can
rapidly build and deliver deploy those
into uh kind of a production environment
they can leverage and then for larger
more complex pieces of software
um think of an Amazon with its uh Amazon
web services or just the products they
offer Google Six Sigma becomes really
powerful because again all this Rich
data that's flowing in and you can use
that to analyze you know how responsive
is your software uh how how are people
using your software are they kind of
using the way that was intended and if
not what can you do improve their
experience so yes lean 16 may use
extensively in the software development
domain
yeah in fact uh as you mentioned agile
kind of flows out of the software
development domain
and it flows out for the reason that
um previously waterfall methods of of
managing software projects would lead to
a lot of ways because you get to the end
of a project phase and realize that the
requirements have changed right where by
changing the way software development
was done the amount of wasted effort was
was changed
exactly saved
um
call the Assurance engineer how can I
make myself more perfect with lean Six
Sigma for a better future so
that's kind of an introspective question
but
what are the things that that this adds
to a quality assurance engineers
kind of well-rounded toolkit absolutely
well as a quality assurance engineer of
course you're interested in
understanding how can we ensure as you
mentioned you know quality is embedded
in the work that we're doing and uh and
one of the important things that lean
identifies lean's all about identifying
waste what are sources of waste well it
could be defects right we want to
minimize the number of defects and
there's a quality assurance engineer
you're trying to do the same thing so
lean's going to help us uh leverage
tools techniques like the Dometic that
we heard about to help you better
understand where to focus your time to
improve and increase those efficiencies
reduce defects
um the Six Sigma part of this is going
to give you uh techniques to kind of
analyze the data that might help you
better extend as a quality insurance
engineer where are your processes are
you kind of conforming to that Six Sigma
standard
and if you aren't uh figuring out okay
where do we have outliers let's let's
dig into those let's understand you know
why those are occurring what can we do
to prevent them from happening again so
uh there's actually no question if you
are in quality assurance you really need
to have lean system on your toolbox
because uh that's a it's an important
tool you can be leveraging all the time
um
question about
can you talk a little bit about what
jira is for sure sure yeah and you might
not have come across as jira is um it's
a product offered by a company called
atlassian atlassian is based on
Australia they have a number of products
jira specifically is a Work Management
product so uh think about you know if
you've got tickets coming in to a help
desk queue or you've got maybe a a
product that has features that you want
to keep track of assigned to people have
them provide updates on their progress
so that's what jira is used for it's
going to help organizations track how
they respond to uh you know issues and
and deliver features and enhancements uh
to their products and it would be
similar to if you've you know had some
exposure to products like perhaps Azure
devops well Ado jira very similar in how
they work together there's quite a few
other products out there in the market I
would say jira's Pro probably if not the
biggest one of the biggest top three for
sure in this space and this is again why
simply Gardens identified it as an
important product to get some exposure
to and some experience with because
you're going to find it used in so many
different organizations
thank you
we have a question from someone who's
Kumar is a post-grad in industrial
engineering
took lean Six Sigma as part of their
quality engineering course
um is this going to take him in more
depth and is it valuable to him
yeah I mean you might this might be a
good place to spend a little time with
the uh simply learned learning
Consultants they can help you spend you
get a better understanding of the
details of course because we'd have to
compare it
um with what you you've learned already
but here is I think the part that you
might not have had as much exposure to
if you're a postgrad industrial
engineering is these master classes the
partnership you're going to have with
leading industry experts from KPMG
um that is an experience that I don't
think you're going to be able to find in
many other settings so my my my
intuition is telling me that this is
going to deeply enrich that Foundation
that you already have and I I think
you'd probably get a lot from this as
well as the ability to apply to these
real world very contemporary
um examples that we're going to Leverage
we have another question from someone
who has a master's in project management
okay is this a good compliment to that
oh no doubt about it yeah you've got a
master's project management and you know
I say this is a person who does uh spent
a lot of time the project management do
a lot of work project management
Institute this is a fantastic fit I use
lean Six Sigma practices all the time in
my project and program delivery so
um it's an indispensable tool to have
your tool kit if you work in that space
all right
um and we mentioned in U.S and India for
some of the services we provide and
pricing
for people in other regions in other
countries
this is available worldwide delivery is
uh digital and you can access it from
anywhere in the world
um the main difference here is that we
don't provide the job assist program
outside the US and India one of the
aspects of the program but for every
other aspect of the program it's there
it's available to you and
um
again to find out about the pricing you
can either email us and ask us
simplylearn.net or you can go to our a
website and I'll share the
URL for that page
shortly
admission is through email first that is
correct you do send us an email and the
lending consultant will let you know
what other information needs to be sent
and
let's go into the chat because that
takes me to the bottom of the Q a
you can go to the chat and see
if you're a data science
if you're in a data scientist course
it's Six Sigma important
yeah I would I think the simple answer
is yes absolutely
um you know data scientists of course
are working with a lot of data and Six
Sigma is going to be an invaluable tool
to help you really understand you know
how to interpret that data and as this
data you know conforming to what you
would expect in terms of different
ranges and where do you want to focus on
outliers it might be affecting or
influencing your process performance so
yeah no question about that if you're
data scientist you'd find a lot of value
uh in in using or leveraging some of
these Six Sigma techniques okay
uh the question that uh I'm not sure
that you're familiar with the term will
it help in cold chain management do you
recognize that term I have to confess
it's not when I'm immediately familiar
with but we can certainly speak to
Supply Chain management and uh again if
there's a relationship between cold
chain and supply chain uh the the simple
answer is absolutely you're going to use
these techniques uh in a variety of
different ways if you think of supply
chain
we really want to find way areas that we
can improve the efficiency of so anytime
we're seeing a supply chain where
there's wait times waiting for products
to kind of get loaded or
um you know shipped things like that we
want to find ways we can reduce those
wait times we want to again look at our
our sort of our our performance using
that bell curve that we're all familiar
with and ensure that you know the
majority of our shipments are within
that acceptable range maybe we've got a
contractual commitment you know Amazon
and it's you know same day delivery well
they're probably studying pretty closely
how many things are delivered in that
same day how many things are falling
outside at the window what can we do to
kind of get those back in the window so
uh yeah supply chain uses these
techniques extensively
okay and I'm gonna ask one last question
because we've
gone over time but
uh
irvalda asks
do you still need lean Six Sigma since
we have
AI methods like chat GPT that can
help us in our work
well I think you kind of answered that
question a little earlier didn't you
whether you said hey you know right now
it's at GPT it's a pretty high error
rate
um now you know we we would use these
techniques identify how can we both
understand where those errors are coming
from how can we find ways that can
reduce those errors so there's no doubt
about it behind the scenes of every good
chat GPT are going to be a collection of
uh of different skill sets ensuring what
it's producing and and sharing to its
customers is accurate and I think this
words can be so important to have these
skills yeah there's a recent example of
a non-profit organization that wanted to
improve
the efficiency of delivery of advice to
people
young people with eating disorders
um and they came up with a chat bot that
would allow
people to interact with it so that they
didn't have to have as many human
counselors answering the phone
uh it's a great idea the problem is that
the chat bot would do things like tell
people who were asking about anorexia
which is the inability to eat or the
this inclination to eat enough they're
telling them things about how to go on a
diet
uh very quickly they realized this chat
bot was doing far more harm than good
and they went back to their old way of
doing things but when we talk about what
artificial intelligence will be able to
do in the future
there are two things to know one is it's
not there yet and two when it is there
it's people who know how to use it will
be able to apply it into whatever field
they're they're in so
in order to be able to use it
effectively in quality management
have the grounding in lean Six Sigma so
that you understand what it is you want
the AI to do for you and so you can
understand whether it's doing the right
thing and what advice to take from it so
with that I want to move on to my last
question for our audience
last question for our audience is
those of you who are interested in
program would you like us to reach out
directly to you
leave this open for just another
10 seconds
the numbers are changing a little bit
three two one and
so a little over half of you would like
that and we will have one of our
learning Consultants reach out to you
um
in the meantime for the rest of you
please reach out to us through the email
and I'll put into the chat again
that email address along with the
web page URL for our program page
be able to see
things there like
your
the chat
oh here I am
your local
currency and price information will be
there and
you'll also be able to contact us
through the web page as well so there's
the URL along with the email address
the QR code can take you to that URL as
well and
that
brings us to the end of our webinar I
want to thank Brian for being
extremely helpful generous with the time
and knowledge and especially patient
with all of the glitches that I was
having up front so I really thank you
for that absolutely well thanks for the
opportunity great great experience love
the questions engagements so for those
who are still with us thanks so much for
uh for attending was uh it was a great
experience and again we will be sending
you a follow-up email with a link to
this recording to be able to
watch Zoom
torture me for a while before we get
into the material and I want to thank
every one of you for being here taking
time out of your day your evening your
morning to
join us to find out about this program
we hope we can welcome you into our
Learning Community with the University
of Massachusetts at Amherst and simply
learn
that concludes our webinar thank you so
much take care